nous allons tenter d'y voir plus clair
maintenant sur ce plateau de débat doc
en compagnie de nos invités en
commençant par vous docteur Arnaud Cocol
bienvenue à vous vous êtes médecin
nutritionniste vous êtes spécialisé dans
le traitement du surpoids et puis
généralement des troubles du
comportement alimentaire la docteur
Marion Lagneau est également avec nous
bienvenue et vous êtes
gastro-entérologue et trésorière du
collectif no fake Med c'est un collectif
qui comme son nom l'indique se mobilise
contre les fausses informations liées à
la médecine et puis enfin Margot Brunet
est avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste science et santé à
l'hebdomadaire Marianne ce documentaire
que nous venons de voir maintenant plus
de 10 ans il y a sans doute matière à le
remettre au goût du jour nous allons
faire peut-être ensemble si vous en êtes
d'accord tout au long de cette émission
il y figure néanmoins un certain nombre
d'informations sur
je voulais vous demander pour commencer
votre avis aux uns et aux autres pour
essayer justement de démêler le vrai du
faux concernant les informations qui
figurent dans le film que nous venons de
voir en commençant par celle-ci quarante
années d'études scientifiques
existeraient en URSS
sur des milliers de malades et ces
études n'auraient pas été traduites et
seraient donc totalement inconnue
aujourd'hui encore en Occident vrai ou
faux alors on peut se poser des
questions mais comme vous le dites c'est
l'ex Union Soviétique donc on peut se
poser les questions sur les volontaires
telles qu'ils étaient en Sibérie donc je
ne sais pas trop quel était le mode de
recrutement des volontaires en Sibérie
avec les modes de alimentaires qui
pouvaient prévaloir à cette époque donc
on peut se poser des questions pourquoi
ça pas été publié parce que il y avait
peut-être pas une légitimité
scientifique
qui autorise à des publications dans des
revues à comité de lecture international
bon c'est peut-être un petit peu
l'interrogation vous en aviez
connaissance à titre personnel ou alors
c'est une j'avais lu le bouquin de
Thierry de l'estrade qui fait référence
qui a le même titre que le reportage le
jeûne une nouvelle
thérapieds et donc qui qui ont fait état
donc j'ai pas vu pour être abonné moi
des revues scientifiques médicales il y
a aucun aucune bibliographie qui fait
référence à ses études là donc j'en ai
pas trouvé j'ai réactualisé pour
l'émission mais j'ai pas trouvé de
référence de référencement quant à des
auteurs russes ou soviétiques qui ferait
en la matière donc il y a des
interrogations même si actuellement en
2023 il y a énormément de publications
sur le jeûne donc c'est vrai que c'est
un sujet qui passionne quand même la
communauté scientifique il est question
de la famille buffinger qui qui dispose
de plusieurs cliniques outre en
Allemagne alors nous avons visitons deux
celles qui au bord du lac de Constance
d'une part et puis l'autre qui est situé
à à Berlin là-bas il y aurait une voilà
après d'un siècle là aussi de d'études
qui auraient été fournies de pour cette
fameuse famille
Buchinger oui on attendra de ces études
je peux pas dire bon même si le médecin
qui figure dans le reportage le
professeur qui est à l'hôpital de la
Charité tout ça a fait référencement
donc bon ce qui est intéressant dans le
reporter je rappelle quand même qu'il y
a 25% pratiquement des Allemands qui ont
fait une cure de jeûne bon je rappelle
quand même que l'Allemagne c'est un
petit peu nos américains nous c'est à
dire que c'est parmi les plus obèses des
Européens donc le jeûne comme réponse au
problème sociétaux qui sont mentionnés
en dans la présentation ça interpelle
quand même parce que le jeûne n'a pas
l'air de freiner malgré tout cette
pandémie d'obésité qu'on observe et en
particulier en Allemagne ainsi que
toutes ces maladies tout ce qui est tel
que sont le diabète les maladies
cardiovasculaires donc fait état
régulièrement et également dans le
reportage avec des
supposés bénéfices du jeûne donc il y a
beaucoup d'interrogations moi le point
d'interrogation je rajoute beaucoup
alors concernant ces points
d'interrogation vous en avez noté
d'autres à la suite du visionnage de ce
documentaire
alors je trouve qu'il y a des choses qui
font sourire dans ce qui se passe en
Russie d'abord on vous présente une
médecine qui n'existe plus avec un
médecin ou des médecins qui ont des
jolies blues bien fermés et des
infirmières à cornettes
c'est peut-être encore l'espoir de
certains mais c'est une médecine qui
n'existe plus le jeune sous supervision
comme ça et ensuite on vous évoque
des études qui figurent dans des
documents poussiéreux qui sont eux-mêmes
dans des rayons poussiéreux qu'on nous
montre d'ailleurs et on nous dit que le
génie est là dedans mais n'a jamais vous
mettez vraiment mis à la connaissance du
monde entier et franchement des génies
méconnus il y en a mais des choses
géniales comme ça qui resteraient
méconnues pendant
plus de 100 ans parce que ça date du
début du 20e siècle on a du mal à y
croire quoi s'il y avait vraiment eu des
études qui étaient faites
scientifiquement
et bien elles auraient elles seraient
sorties d'Union soviétique et comme le
dit le docteur Cocol c'est vrai qu'on
peut aussi un petit peu douter de des
sujets d'études parce qu'on parle
beaucoup de psychiatrie sur ces sujets
là et on sait que
Union soviétique et psychiatrie c'est
peut-être la matière à un autre débat
peut-être parce qu'il est aussi dit dans
ce documentaire qu'un certain nombre de
d'études portent sur des maladies
mentales alors on parle de notamment de
la schizophrénie dans ce dans ce film là
c'est aussi un terrain qui soulève
beaucoup d'interrogations
pour faire une étude sur le jeûne déjà
il faut qu'on ait des personnes qui ont
ait envie d'y participer ensuite si on
veut faire une étude qu'on appelle en
aveugle c'est-à-dire où les participants
savent pas s'il reçoivent ou non le
traitement c'est très compliqué parce
que forcément quelqu'un qui qui fait un
jeune il sait qui fait un jeune donc on
peut pas faire d'étude en aveugle et
puis au-delà de ça et c'est là que je
rejoins que vous disiez tout à l'heure
sur les personnes qui participent à ces
études là dans le jeûne il y a aussi une
notion qui est très importante c'est la
motivation or on peut pas quand
quelqu'un décide de participer à une
étude sur le jeûne on peut pas forcément
ça veut dire qu'elle est motivée pour le
faire donc on peut pas discerner quand
cette personne-là dit qu'elle se sent
mieux qu'elle a une amélioration de son
humeur si c'est parce qu'elle était très
motivée à participer à cette étude là ou
si c'est le jeune en lui-même qui a
amélioré son état peut-être son humeur
ou son état de santé alors autre élément
avancé dans ce film et vous évoquez des
des études qui pourraient être
compliquées à mettre en place il est dit
dans une que ça pourrait être des études
coûteuses et que on manque d'argent pour
pour ses études et
une des explications données par
documentaire c'est parce que le Big
Pharma les grands laboratoire
pharmaceutiques d'accepteraient même pas
l'idée de voir financer de telles études
parce qu'évidemment ça irait contre
leurs intérêts qu'est-ce que vous pensez
cet argument mise en avant dans ce
documentaire je pense qu'en 2023 c'est
corrigé maintenant parce qu'on bénéficie
d'études surtout il y a beaucoup
d'auteurs chinois leur là-bas ils ont
des modes de recrutement qui sont très
importants et sur le jeûne puisque vous
savez dans toutes les religions en fait
y compris dans le bouddhisme l'enduisme
etc on parle de du jeûne comme comme
bénéfice pour épurer etc donc c'est
rentré dans l'air du temps et c'est
mondial un petit peu cette cette
réflexion autour effectivement est-ce
qu'on va pas trouver un bénéfice à
jeûner donc les auteurs chinois ils
recrutent énormément avec des études qui
sont quand même publiées dans des revues
internationales un comité de lecture
donc elles sont quand même validées et
avec un nombre de participants des
cordes qu'on appelle des cordes c'est à
dire des groupes de participants qui
sont assez conséquents donc et qui de
dire que le jeûne peut-être une voix
intéressante sont les études ça serait
plutôt le jeu d'intermittent nocturne on
en parlera peut-être bien sûr voilà qui
pourrait être intéressant et les auteurs
concluent dans des ce qu'on appelle des
méta-analyses les méta-analyses c'est
vraiment des observations globales
d'études et c'est vraiment et c'est une
force un pouvoir statistique et
extrêmement puissant et les auteurs
concluent avec juste raison je trouve
que ça s'adresse pas à tout le monde
c'est ça qui est important il y a des
gens et moi j'ai des passions qui ont pu
faire du jeûne mais pas tel que c'est
pas du jeune total tel qu'on le voit
dans le reportage mais du jeune
intermittent nocturne que je peux
écouter et que je peux encourager dans
certains cas mais certains de mes
patients n'ont pas pu suivre donc ça
s'adresse pas à tout le monde est-ce que
les études
en faveur
du jeûne thérapeutique irréal à
l'inverse des intérêts de l'industrie
pharmaceutique est-ce que ça vous paraît
une thèse possible
c'est dur de répondre
dans un sens oui parce que ça c'est pas
du médicament et donc derrière il y en a
pas de rentabilité parce qu'en fait on
prend la l'absence de traitement plus
que quelque chose de thérapeutique donc
c'est vrai que on conçoit que le
laboratoire soit moins intéressé par
quelque chose qui au des cours de cette
étude ne rapportera pas de d'argent mais
je pensais à ce reportage sur sur la
clinique allemande
où on voit un sympathique monsieur qui
est un autre mangeur anonyme un outre
mangeur et un autre un autre buveur un
anonyme d'ailleurs il s'en cache pas et
qui vient solder son année d'excès par
15 jours de jeûne et en fait une étude
simple ça serait de comparer pour la
santé de différents patients si c'est
mieux d'aller se purifier de faire une
sorte de dry January dans une clinique
d'ailleurs
ou si c'est mieux de faire 350 autres
jours de d'alimentation raisonnable
parce qu'en fait c'est pas entre Noël et
le nouvel an qu'on gros si c'est entre
le Nouvel An et Noël vous voyez docteur
Andreas mikelsen chef de service hôpital
de la charité à Berlin vous situez tout
à l'heure il cite des études qui selon
lui pour être intéressantes et même
nécessaire concernant le jeu concernant
l'arthrose l'arthrite rhumatismale le
diabète l'hypertension et ça dire que
concernant ces maladies dont certaines
sont chroniques le jeûne pourrait avoir
un intérêt et mériterait des études pour
aller au-delà
mais que je ne peux mériter des études
je pense que personne dit le contraire
il y a certaines études qui ont été
faites notamment sur la polyarthrite
rhumatoïde
la solitude dont on considère qu'elle a
été bien faite sur le sujet et encore on
pense que que ça manque de patients qui
ont été inclus elle date du début des
années 90 donc qu'il faut peut-être
amplifier les études sur le sujet qu'il
faut emmener etc là-dessus je pense je
peux me tromper mais je pense qu'il y a
pas de débat le problème c'est quand on
pose ça comme étant déjà un état de fait
mais qu'il fallait continuer
potentiellement à étudier le jeûne
s'assurer que si il y a pas assez
d'études qui sont faites c'est pas à
cause comme on le disait tout à l'heure
de l'industrie pharmaceutique etc
pourquoi pas le problème ce serait
d'avoir le raisonnement inverse les
faits sur les maladies chroniques il en
a été souvent question dans ce film
c'est assez récurrent la semble-t-il le
jeûne quel que soit la forme qu'il prend
peut avoir un intérêt et peut résoudre
les problèmes des patients vous savez on
a un exemple de jeûne classique et qui
revient chaque année c'est le ramadan
quand même donc
les personnes qui suivent le ramadan moi
j'en vois pas mal dans ma patientèle et
qu'est-ce que j'observe j'observe des
troubles du comportement alimentaire
avec une perte de poids la première
semaine qui est constaté dans les études
et une reprise Allègre avec allégresse
dans les semaines qui suivent donc les
troubles du comportement alimentaire
sont extrêmement pris non c'est ça donc
j'ai peur moi j'ai des passions qui se
soumettent à des régimes restrictifs et
le jeûne peut faire partie d'un
restriction donc il mangera rien à part
de l'eau et ses patients soumettent leur
corps un petit peu comme la pénurie
d'essence vous voyez on a vu les hors de
d'automobiliste qui avait plus assez
d'essence dans leur réservoir mais qui
faisait la queue pendant des heures à la
station-service avec des jerrican si
possible pour stocker le corps humain
c'est un petit peu ça c'est ça dont j'ai
peur et j'ai un petit peu peur vous
parliez de la clinique buckinger moi
j'ai l'impression qu'il allait chaque
année à la clinique buckinger homme
d'affaires qui avait des moyens de payer
4000 ou 5000 euros la semaine pour rien
manger et qui revenait très content
parce qu'il perdu c'est 7 kg etc et qui
dans l'année qui suivait retrouvé ses
agapes quotidiens etc son mode de vie
son manque de sommeil etc son absence de
d'activité physique et résultat prenez
10 kg donc chaque année en fait son
solde montée petit à petit avec une
période d'une semaine qui ne servit
strictement à rien comme vous disiez
tout à l'heure parce que son mode de vie
ne changeait pas en dehors donc c'est ça
le problème c'est est-ce qu'on est prêt
dans ce cas-là à se soumettre à un jeu
en permanence donc il y a peut-être des
gens qui sont prêts à voir un déficit
calorique quotidien permanent dans ce
cas là ils arriveront effectivement
peut-être à soigner certaines maladies
sociétales qui sont liées à notre
malbouffe
qui sont liées à notre mauvaise mode de
vie donc c'est vrai que la malbouffe
génère des maladies on peut pas le
critiquer les maladies inflammatoires
mais là je pense que on peut il faut
faire attention à la définition
également du jeûne il y a différents
types de jeunes on y reviendra peut-être
mais non on va y venir maintenant
les jeunes intermittents vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure j'ai sous les yeux
quatre types de jeunes dit intermittents
pour nous en dire un peu plus sur sur
ces jeunes intermittents ça c'est très à
la mode semble-t-il aujourd'hui aussi
dans une partie de la population et
notamment chez les CSP plus que vous
avez vu tout à l'heure à travers des
stages de jeunes par exemple qui sont
mis en place on va y revenir pas
toujours d'ailleurs par un avec un
encadrement médical
les types de jeunes aujourd'hui
existants cocolle répondra mieux alors
il y a le 5-2 où on mange cinq jours on
arrête de manger deux jours il y a un
jour sur deux on mange une journée et
pas le lendemain et puis après il y a
les jeunes dans la journée c'est à dire
qu'en fait on doit 16 heures ou 18h et
faire un seul repas en réalité
on mange tôt le soir on saute le petit
déjeuner et on poursuit jusqu'à 13 14
heures de façon à avoir 8 heures de
d'alimentation et
16 heures de non-alimentation
moi pour moi ça revient tout ça dans le
trouble du comportement alimentaire
c'est c'est la gastro-entérologue qui
peut pas s'empêcher de dire ça et puis
alors il y a pas que ce genre de jeu en
fait il y a les jeunes sélectifs aussi
il y a aussi beaucoup de gens qui
suppriment certains aliments le gluten
pour ne pas le nommer le lait et puis
plein d'aliments qui sont diabolisés
par différentes personnes qu'ils auront
pu consulter d'ailleurs en qui ils ont
confiance et avec d'ailleurs c'est très
étonnant autant il y a peu d'adhésions
au traitement médicaux autant à la
suppression alimentaire il y a une
adhésion qui m'a toujours beaucoup
étonné
et moi j'ai vu plusieurs fois en
consultation des gens qui arrivaient à
plus rien manger parce qu'ils avaient vu
un premier médecin qui avait supprimé le
gluten ça marchait pas un deuxième avait
supprimé le lait et ça fonctionnait pas
non plus un troisième avait diabolisé
n'importe quel aliment les tomates sont
souvent pas très bien compris pourquoi
les tomates étaient l'objet de d'une
telle diabolisation au final il mangeait
des pâtes du riz
il perdait aussi toute forme de
réunion de réunions en société parce que
ça permet pas de vivre normalement donc
c'est aussi sur sur ces effets dérivés
d'une alimentation différente qu'on peut
s'intéresser
sur ces différents types de jeunes et
les jeunes peut-être les plus pratiqués
aujourd'hui
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de types de
jeunes qui sont pratiqués aujourd'hui
parfois voilà ça va être ça à supprimer
un aliment etc
ce qui est aussi de plus en plus
pratiqué c'est ce qu'on appelle le jeune
strict le jeune strict c'est cette fois
on se permet de ne rien manger on
continue à boire de l'eau parce que de
toute façon si on boit pas on est plutôt
dans le cadre de ce qu'on a vu dans ce
film le jeune Street
consomme rien et le problème que ça pose
aujourd'hui c'est que c'est promu par
des personnes qui elles ne sont pas
médecin qui se présentent comme divers
thérapeutes qui peuvent être parfois
naturopathes ou autres voilà forme de
thérapeute non conventionnelle qui eux
mettent en avant des jeunes strictes qui
disent à leur passion plutôt peut-être
client vous ne vous ne mangez rien et ça
peut être parfois pendant des périodes
très très longues il y en a qui font qui
proposent des stages de 5 à 8 jours des
fois c'est beaucoup plus que ça avec de
la randonnée aussi avec une activité
physique etc et ça c'est quelque chose
qui est de plus en plus populaire en
fait c'est quelque chose qui a qui
existe depuis plusieurs années mais qui
a pris un essor considérable pendant la
crise sanitaire pourquoi parce que comme
on le voyait au début du documentaire
tout à l'heure
ce jeune ces nouvelles formes de
thérapie entre guillemets elle
s'accompagne dans le discours qui est
très méfiant vis-à-vis de la médecine
traditionnelle et qui est aussi vu comme
un espèce de refus de ce qu'appelle ce
qu'on appelait au début de ce
documentaire les maladies civilisation
or le covid quand il a été quand il est
arrivé quand il est apparu a été vu par
beaucoup comme une maladie civilisation
qui serait à la conséquence de nos modes
de vie de notre rapprochement de
certains animaux desquels auraient pu
à cause des Calor aurait pu apparaître
le strasscoff 2
théories antivax exactement et du coup
il y a eu une collusion entre le refus
de de ce mode de villa de la médecine la
montée du complotisme etc qui a permis
un essor de ces nouvelles thérapies des
jeunes que certains appellent plutôt
d'ailleurs des purges et depuis deux
trois ans on a une explosion du
phénomène qui est souligné chaque dans
le rapport de la misélude qui est
l'organisme qui qui s'intéresse à toutes
les dérives sectaires et d'ailleurs vous
l'avez utilisé ce terme
récemment jeûner c'est se purger se
purger
c'est remettre les compteurs à zéro
alors il y a comme ça des formules dans
le reportage ils vont même juste
l'hydrothérapie du côlon
en Union soviétique donc il vous faut
des lavements du côlon qui sont pas
dénué de risque parce que là c'est la
guerre
dans l'aberration la plus complète
parfois donc j'imagine que ce que vous
conseiller c'est tout de même un
encadrement strict d'un jeune quel qu'il
soit jeune intermittent jeune Street la
condition première pour se lancer dans
une telle aventure c'est de s'assurer
d'un contrôle médical
on a fait le serment d'Hippocrate et
dedans c'est en premier ne pas nuire
c'est quand même ça donc premium donne
nos séries donc quand je vais impatient
j'essaye de lui faire du bien donc de
regarder le bénéfice risque de ce que je
lui propose quand il y a pas
d'encadrement thérapeutique médical on
est dans la déraison la plus complète
donc avec mettons les influenceurs
j'adore ce terme quelqu'un qui se dit
influenceur je sais pas à quoi ça
correspond et donc vous avez des gens
sur les réseaux sociaux qui vous
racontent n'importe quoi donc là on a
parlé de la covid et qui embrigade
beaucoup de monde voilà et qui en
brigade et qui recrute effectivement les
dérivés secteurs maintenant la terre
n'est pas ronde l'homme n'a jamais été
sur la lune etc les tours sont jamais
tombés etc donc on est toujours dans le
complotisme et là la médecine vous ment
l'industrie pharmaceutique c'est Big
Pharma Big Brother etc bon il y a
certainement des excès je dis pas
l'agroalimentaire aussi il y a des excès
etc mais il y a des gens aussi qui à
côté essayent de faire du bien quand
même et je pense que je préfère être en
2023 et vivre sous mon époque dans une
sécurité alimentaire malgré tout même si
on mange pas forcément bien
il y avait que des médicaments qui
m'attendent sont quand même plus
surveillés mais il y a eu des dérives on
a vu dans le reportage médiator et
d'histoire du Médiator la boîte était
montrée au début le Diox etc il y a des
scandales sanitaires mais il faut que ça
reste médical c'est à dire il faut pas
sortir de ce champ et éventuellement
vous confronter les opinions c'est à
dire vous allez voir un autre médecin
pour voir si les deux médecins
s'accordent mais il faut pas aller voir
les les pseudos scientifiques qui sont
des fricothérapeutes or c'est ce qu'on
observe c'est ce que vous observez du
côté de nos fake Med ce collectif qui se
bat justement contre les fausses infos
médicales vous pouvez en dire un peu
plus que ce qui vient d'être dit sur ces
fameuses dérives la différence c'est
pour ça que ce reportage date en fait
c'est que il parle d'un temps où on
parlait encore peut-être entre
guillemets de jeunes thérapeutiques et
effectivement ce qu'on peut souligner
c'est que tous les reportages se font
sous supervisations médicales
mais en fait on est passé du jaune sous
supervisation médicale à la notion de
cure de jeûne et là d'autres gens que
des médecins s'en sont opérés parce que
le médecin pour différentes raisons ont
laissé tomber ça bon d'abord il y a
quand même des thérapeutiques qui sont
plus efficaces certainement beaucoup
plus que de jeûner et
il y a pas d'intérêt particulier de la
médecine pour ce genre de thérapeutique
de nos thérapeutiques donc d'autres que
les médecins ont pu s'en emparer alors
qui est bien
des gens qui ont compris des gens qui
ont des croyances probablement au départ
du moins on l'espère ou en tout cas qui
savent que les autres ont des croyances
et qui vont se conformer à leur
croyances et qui vont vendre croyances
religieuses croyances naturaliste
oui oui en fait on parlait des lavements
on parlait de la vidange en fait
dès lors qu'on parle d'alimentation on
rentre dans quelque chose qui est du
domaine de la purification on fait
rentrer quelque chose dans l'individu
donc on fait rentrer peut-être des
mauvaises choses alors il faut que ça
ressorte donc ça ressorte en gênant
parce que on va se débarrasser des
toxines ça ressortant en faisant des
lavements internes
ça ressort en faisant d'autres
techniques parce que en fait les gens
qui proposent ça
ils proposent jamais ça seul c'est
jamais juste un jeûne maintenant dans le
cadre de cœur de jeunes alors ceux qui
sont spécialement semble-t-il dans le
viseur ce qu'on appelle les naturopathes
aussi alors expliquez-nous qu'est-ce
qu'un bon et un mauvais naturopathe
comment on fait le tri pour ceux que ça
pourrait intéresser néanmoins c'est tout
le problème de la naturopathie le
principe de la naturopathie c'est de se
servir de la nature en elle-même pour
nous guérir il peut y avoir des
naturopathes qui vont exercer
voilà à côté du parcours médical et qui
vont évidemment avoir un discours
bienveillant envers les médecins et dans
ce cas là globalement ça pose pas trop
de problèmes ce qui pose problème c'est
quand le naturopathe lui-même reprend ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure en
premier ne pas nuire premium non local
certains n'a toujours pas reprennent ce
discours là en disant mais parfois la
médecine elle-même peut vous nuire
prenons l'exemple des cancers quelqu'un
qui fait une chimiothérapie la
chimiothérapie elle va pas attaquer
uniquement le cancer elle va attaquer
tout l'organisme parce que c'est un des
effets indésirables de la chimiothérapie
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne et donc
le naturopathe lui va dire mais vous
voyez la chimiothérapie vous nuit donc
il ne faut plus que vous fassiez le
chimmothérapie et c'est à ce moment là
que la naturopathie devient dangereuse
c'est quand elle non plus en parallèle
en complément d'un traitement médical
mais qu'elle vise à à le remplacer pour
éviter ces effets indésirables et c'est
pour ça qu'il y a certains naturopathes
qui y en a un qui a été mis en examen à
la mi-janvier justement après le décès
d'un de ses patients il y en a un autre
il y a un an et demi qui lui avait été
condamné pour
usurpatite usurpation du titre de
médecin exercice il de la médecine après
le décès dans de ses patients à qui
justement il avait alors on peut dire
conseiller si ce n'est en tout cas
imposer d'arrêter sa chimiothérapie
c'est un patient qui avait 44 ans qui
avait un cancer des testicules qui a un
cancer qu'on savait durable sauf que son
naturopathe lui a dit il faut que tu te
purge donc que tu fasses des jeunes
prolongés etc et ne continue pas la
chimiothérapie parce que c'est elle qui
va tenir et donc le patient est décédé
il y avait même une autre patiente alors
j'ai du mal à dire patient parce que cet
homme là était pas médecin plutôt
cliente qui elle avait écouté les
préceptes de ce naturopathe qui était
décédés et pendant le procès que j'avais
suivi à l'époque pour Marianne le
naturopathe en question avait expliqué
non mais attendez pendant son jeûne elle
a rompu le jeune pour aller manger un
burger d'une chaîne de restauration
rapide et il sous-entendait en filigrane
qu'elle était décédée à cause de ce
burger parce que on ne casse pas son
jeûne à cause d'un hamburger le vrai
problème qui a eu à ce moment c'est que
lui il avait un discours
pseudo-médical en fait je laisse le mot
de la fin
la première pollution quand même c'est
notre propre respiration c'est ça qui
nous crée en fait le plus de toxines
c'est-à-dire chaque fois que nous
respirons nous fabriquons ce qu'on
appelle des radicaux libres c'est des
agresseurs sur nos cellules etc et qui
accélère le vieillissement donc en fait
il faudrait que dans ce cas là c'est
pseudo naturopale les du moins les
naturopathes déguisés
avec des vertus soi-disant il devrait
faire arrêter de respirer leur passion
ce serait comme ça qui pourrait les
soigner
du vieillissement et cellulaire donc on
est dans l'aberration on voit bien ça
donc pour moi le seul jaune qui peut
avoir un intérêt si le jeûne
physiologique nocturne qui peut être
augmentée c'est-à-dire augmenter la
plage horaire ils vont te demander et
manger dans un intervalle de temps plus
limité et en fait on s'est rendu compte
que les gens naturellement ils adoptent
de meilleures modes alimentaires et ils
arrivent à c'est vrai améliorer leur
permettre métabolique
[Musique]